first of all I want to sell humble
Salaam alaikum guys how you doing
I'm with Ali professional former
professional fighter how many years 15
years 15 years because they scare
dimension but the kids dying over there
every day
why does not mention we talk about the
Conor McGregor destroying the boss first
UFC champion the history he just made
history yesterday everything is nothing
you know number one believe on your one
god
[Music]
[Music]
our brother Ali Keita cough I said are
they cool greetings of peace how are you
my brother
good hunt a lot so we just had the news
that a training partner with you Habib
having a motivator that you've been
actually you did you grow up with
training with you know each other yeah
yeah there's a friend of mine so you're
actually you were a professional fighter
for 15 how many fifteen years of
professional fighter
tell us a little bit about about that
you know people you train with and a lot
of brothers you know in our region we
have a lotta Muslim brothers they fought
all over the world and now they
represent us in UFC the biggest
organization well oh well we just got
the Habib know magamaev who became the
first Muslim UFC champion in history I
just made history yesterday
[Applause]
lightweight champion of the world copied
the eagle
suppose I wanna sell hamdullah with ours
God we cannot do nothing everything is
nothing you know number one we live on
you're wrong God well yeah start
training went over the five years old it
was competing wrestling [ __ ] kickboxing
more time and then you know my friend
brought me over here and started finding
here professional in Las Vegas Colorado
all over you know in Brazil and you
don't recently a maybe two years ago I
stopped fighting I decided to stop so
that was your your dream I mean you were
telling me about you know many people
don't understand the climate there is it
deca Stan Dagestan Chechnya you know
this is like a cooks malt in this area
where is little countries but a lot of
different languages different flags this
is a countries they just Republic of the
Russia because this was back in the
Soviet Union some hundreds come out of
the Soviet Union became their own
independent countries and some still
stay in Russia so this part of the
Russia you know what I mean yeah there's
a lot of different countries like Church
now in bhushaiah Dagestan satya
kabardino-balkaria can shout UK say most
of this country proper ninety percent is
Muslim countries so yeah there's a lot
of tough people come on over the best
athletes in the world is come out to
this region but you were telling me that
usually the people who end up turning
towards the fighting as an art they
don't have many choices explain that to
me because this is you know this country
you have to know someone to get you know
to get the job or you have to have money
to pay to get the position you know and
is very difficult so there's a lot of
criminals over there
or the people became an athlete's to
support their family there's only way to
make money and the way they pay like
celery in Russia in example you can make
a hundred bucks a month tell me what is
enough to pay nothing you know 100 like
in America what are you gonna pay your
gas if you love the tank so like you
know this
difficult and a lot of people became a
fighters because you can make good
living you don't take care of your
family support your family they don't do
this because it's fun a lot of brothers
know this Haram you know a lot of
brothers there's no other chain chain
you know they don't want they don't
choose it because they have to support
the family they have a big families you
know and all Muslims have a lot of
families and there's not like you just
take care of your mom and dad and your
brother you take care of your cousins
you take care of your third cousins any
take care of all of your neighbors you
know I mean so you kill all the people
some of the other people you were
telling me that you've trained with was
that King mo but he's short as actually
I didn't know he's actually Muslim God
yeah brother yeah how about the other
pros the other brother Osama what's mine
Oman so a lot a lot of a lot of these up
why is it you know a lot of these these
martial artists these UFC fighters MMA
fighters they're courageous you know to
get in the cage and fight but why is it
sometimes you know they're they're not
it seems like they're apologetically
most they're not unapologetically Muslim
especially in this time this climate of
Islamophobia where you think you know
now show the courage that you are and
right you're you're a Muslim you're
proud to be one who has submitted his or
her will to the Almighty to to the
Creator mostly talk about the dislike
you know people who watch the media and
when you see the bearded brother you
know the first what they think is the
terrorist people man as soon as they
open their mouths and actually have a
kind of conversation with the Muslims
they understand this is a basic person
just like you
hey you know what I mean and we do the
same thing you know we worship the God
we we take care of our family we go to
work we come back home to our kids you
know so when you introduce yourself to
the people they actually hope in mind
and then you know but mostly people they
don't even meet the mister Muslims
no never talked to them but this
brothers day like this because most of
them bees have no knowledge about Islam
at all all they know is their
grandparents was a Muslim they have a
Muslim names and that's all evolved you
know they know but if you know about
Islam you go Dipper I was there too most
of us it was Josh's back in the days we
don't know nothing when you know more
about Islam allow up in your heart and
you Prague because you're the chosen one
to became Muslim and hamdulillah you
know this is the greatest gift Allah can
give it to the person when they know
that they all became proud you know the
brother Mossad backtick you know he was
weak but when he knows his roots and he
started going to the Masjid this was
completely different person he was
became way more religious than me I see
him in every budget over there and all
your mom start telling me he seemed over
there every lecture he's over there so
Paola you know when you get closer to
Allah you just crazy yeah that's
absolutely right when you you build this
confidence it's just like someone who
comes on the mat does wrestling jujitsu
they don't have the confidence they
don't know the techniques right the more
you grow in it the more your confidence
same thing with with Islam where the
more you dwell into it the more you gain
this conviction that's it's indeed from
the Creator right and then you're proud
to represent it you know and Muslims
simply one for those that haven't been
tuning in this is one who submits their
will to the crater you weren't always a
Muslim talk to us about that
yeah born in the Christian family I
actually grew up on there well actually
my people was they was worship the
mountains the trees and the stuff like
that back in the day we have a big
history like a landing people some
aliens there's like huge history back in
the days you know people very very
racist and proud of their you know blood
line and all that stuff because as we
like back in the day this was a big
warriors and it was actually you know
became the Christians back in the days
but we always have a Muslim but little
small community back in Soviet Union
that was trying to kill their religion
at all as a matter what religion this
was I was trying to take the people away
from religion completely you know making
them focus make everybody equal
everybody here ball the communism so but
now you know the Islam is raising up
over there the brothers start to go into
the Masjid stuff to learn more a lot of
people go on and study in Mecca and
Medina
you know and bring and you know a lot of
young people start to be proud of who
they are
well I grew up in the Christian family
very strong Christian family and I start
to have adults because you know the
church do one thing in the Bible talk
about the different things like in
example Ten Commandments the first
commandment says the God only one so my
husband was the Trinity come and all
this in a New Testament then asking
about the second commandment about the
idols about the drying oldest pictures
this is a scene it's forbidden okay
let's go farther the Bible says you not
allowed to eat the swine so why they eat
the pork we're in the Bible even in New
Testament says you can do that then
there's a bunch of bunch of stuff the
woman has to cover her hair this is in
the Bible too and what actually in a
Russian Church what they do what was
confusing me woman covered their hair to
go to the church as soon they were
called it take the color out this
doesn't make no sense and a lot of stuff
they do they go and they worship the
idols they draw the pictures they come
to these pictures and say over this holy
days holy dead but the jesus never
taught this he never teach this and
there's no mention about this in the
Bible where he call himself was a
Christian where he called himself is
Jaeho witnesses or anything else so this
was my main concern I was asked you know
he's even his name wasn't Jesus he was
issuing you know and I asked a lot of
people to show me original Bible if you
guys have it so I ask a lot of questions
they confused me so in this way as my
journey started master browsing and
learning a lot about Islam and
everything this makes sense this is very
simple God is one he creators she sang
as the guidance and tell us what to do
it's very simple and there's no
confusing it is no Trinity like trained
one father son and somebody else and
there's no confusion they straight up
and forward clear so I became a Muslim a
little nut and that's exactly what
connects with the person who is sincere
he's genuine she
looking for the truth is this pure
monotheism that God like you said it's
only one worshipping the creator and not
the creation and this connects with the
heart you don't have to do a bunch of
mental gymnastics to try to make it you
know fit it's clear it makes sense
has the evidence and you have the Quran
temper free time for proof as we often
say it's a living miracle so what was it
now how did you get exposed to Islam and
what was it now you know the simple
message and how long did it take you
because there are a lot of people I'm
sure you talked to also a lot of people
but now they're scared of like you know
the peer pressure what are people gonna
say you follow me all the negative hype
with the media even fighters people who
you often think are very courageous you
know I mean but now when it comes to
this you know they're like they don't
want to be associated with it so what
was it about Islam and was it something
that you you found the courage right
from the beginning to dwell right into
because you know when you started
getting close to a line you leave the
way he told you to leave you open your
heart and all the fear and everything in
your heart just disappear all you think
about is to make Allah happy and don't
worry about nothing else who think about
you whatever nothing matter all the
matter what a lot of things about you
and make him happy he sounded the he
sent us to guidance the Quran the Holy
Quran when you read it the front talking
to you this is living miracle so much
beautiful beautiful stuff in this book
if you read it it's just mind-blowing
you know and somehow Allah when you know
that when you know Allah with you you
feel it you know you see it in your life
you don't fear or scared or nothing you
said hamdulillah and you represent your
religion because every person gonna
judge you judge your religion by you
they looking at you and they judge your
religion the way you're representing
yourself the way you walk in the way you
dress in the way you're talking the
people gonna look and they think about
the Muslims so the Muslims acting like
that on the public this is what they
think about us when you represent your
religion the way the prime Muhammad said
he said I'll tell us then we showed the
beauty of this religion so I encourage
all the Muslims your Muslims this
blessing from the Allah subhanAllah just
think about the creator of the universe
he make you being a Muslim amongst all
that people
he choose you to be to be in the
paradise you know I mean subhanAllah
open your hearts and start learning and
be proud of your religion because
there's the most beautiful thing this
doesn't matter who thinks would and who
you know subhanAllah this we what we do
we pray five times a day we eat halal
food we treat the people nice we follow
all the commandments and it and they
consider us as a bad people and on
because we're doing all their things
there's a matter of who thinks what
Allah knows your heart or not Allah
knows your attention so there's nothing
to fear of it like I say this is a level
of Iman in every person your iman is
very low you know this way you all want
this I'm in the media I'm a superstar if
I'm gonna start talking about to God you
know these days you know how it is with
the people when you start talking about
the God and kind of push you away you
know what I mean because you know people
healthy and strong but as soon as when
the airplane and the airplane is about
to crash even at least scream god help
me god help me so then everybody's hard
so like I say this is all to make a
dollar to the people so they understand
who they are they understand their
religion I have you know talked to some
brothers some brothers gave this
conclusion the shaitaan' devil himself
was a fallen angel this came from the
christianity this is how misguided they
are so how can you talk to these people
when they don't know nothing about this
religion they were you know you tell
them
give me translation on the surat
al-fatiha they just pray this return
fatiha they don't even know what they
say you have to this obligation and you
as a Muslim to learn about your religion
to represent your religion and
understand what it is it's not just
doing what your parents teach you to do
you know there's not like brushing the
teeth you don't know why you're brushing
your teeth for you have to learn your
religion you have to you have to know
what you're doing it's very important
like I said this brothers miscarriage
because in Russia there's different
situation - when you have a beard like
this they already consider you is a
criminal you know what I mean just by
growing a beard but this is hypocrisy
because every one of them have a little
picture of the Jesus with a big beard so
here you have this picture and you say
he's the greatest man you guys worship
Him and then you see the person with the
building I came dressed just look look
look on him leave the lifestyle
like him you say he's the dirty he's a
terrorist doesn't make sense to me so
let's talk about Ali let's talk a little
bit about the responsibility you
mentioned that the more you learned your
Deen your religion submission to the
will of the Creator Allah Islam and you
started to implement it you actually
your dream was to be a UFC fighter yeah
and you gave that up and you mentioned
something in Arabic word that it was it
was something that was Haram this is
prohibited if this is something now that
we see a lot of what people will
perceive as violence there and people
tried to equate Muslims as being violent
this is not even you know and many
people they leave off like you have
fighting like you did in general because
of your religion that's profound you
left it because your religion prohibits
you from hitting another human being an
animal let alone a human being you know
doing any harm to him right so now this
is something that kind of goes opposite
to what's currently known but let's say
so talk to me about that what was it
that you finally okay because you
struggled with this for years you know
talk to me about this plan when you do
something all your life and there's all
you know like today an example you have
a cell phone right trying to take the
cell phone away it's like you have no
hands so I learned this and this is all
I did in my life you know and just this
is just you have to give up on this this
is very difficult waste especially for
the people who is in the high level and
superstars who cannot even walk away in
the street without getting out to
girlfriend so this was difficult for me
but guess what when you learn about
Islam they Allah open your heart and you
understand if you're a believer when you
see the red light and you know if you're
gonna drive through this red line you're
gonna get the ticket so why you think if
Allah tell you something this is harm
it's forbidden for you and you don't do
this you think you're not gonna get
punished so why is that it's how can you
consider yourself as a believer if you
don't do what Allah tell you to do this
is all the rage
and you say you love the prophets ELISA
these days you know when you tell the
people this is a Sunnah you have to do
the Sunnah grow your beard there's this
if all this Sunnah I don't have to do it
how you don't have to do when the line
the Quran says who do not listen my
prophets and it's enough he don't follow
me he sent us as the guidance he give us
the prophesies so we can follow
completely everything he taught us and
teaches you know but MMA fighters most
of them there's a very good brothers you
know they follow on everything but like
I say there's different different
countries different rules like an
example American fighters days become
what they want to get famous because
they want to get money because they want
to get woman whatever it is you know my
people because they don't have no food
in the table because they want to feed
their family this way they have to do it
this is a different you know it's not
because they want to be famous and round
they don't need all that they need to
have money to take care of their mothers
and fathers brothers and sisters to give
them education like any other people to
take care of their wives and stuff like
this because there's no other income in
this countries it's very difficult to
run the business or do stuff like that
it's why they have to do with it but
most of them is very religious brothers
and very good brothers who is understand
that you just want to get the money and
go out so let's talk for a few about the
people that ok they're not at this
moment gonna leave and let's say okay
you want to now you've gotten that spot
like the fame you've gotten that visit
you've gotten the belt let's say like
our dear brother our beloved brother
Habib's right now what are you gonna do
with that you know that Allah the
Almighty he doesn't care about the UFC
belt he don't care about you know the
dunya he don't care what how many
championships you got but what are you
gonna do now to help share the message
to be the best example that you can be
especially when you have the whole world
literally fighting against Islam what
are you gonna do so what advice do you
have like for people like Habib now you
have the responsibility to not join in
with the conor mcgregor's you know what
I mean
get into the gangster things no but to
be a the best example that you can be so
people can now and now you know they
wear the Reebok you know the sponsorship
but now who's our sponsor are you brave
enough courageous enough to connect
everything that we do now what do you do
what's he going to do now they see you
praying hey I'm taking a timeout to
thank my Creator you know connect
everything back and remind people it's
not our job to convert anybody but to
remind to wake up what's in the human
being in the fitrah that you have a
creator you have a purpose so what
advice that we can like wake up and
motivate many of these brothers out
there who are doing it and they don't
have any plan on leaving anytime soon
but at least to go ahead and do the
dower hobby even in the first place
he's a very good role model for young
people cuz he grew up is a very good
person he's very religious if you see
him every fight you're always greeting
that Allah he say Ally is number one I
wanna sell hamdullah you know Allah
always have better parenting we have
tomorrow
tomorrow god have plan inshallah doesn't
matter what's gonna happen I'm gonna go
keep forward keep going and make history
so thank you so much
he's who give me everything and there's
nothing come from it is everything come
from Allah and he always say
alhamdulillah he said Allah Akbar and he
never shame and he never put his head
down
he always representing always proud to
be a Muslim when a lot of other people
putting their head downs and stuff like
this but the person in his position when
he knows if he gonna talk this way a lot
of people gonna turn away in the fans
and all this media and stuff he don't
care because he representing his
religion he's a good brother insha'Allah
he became here completion everything in
the sport with Kenny man he became a UFC
world champion you know insha'Allah
Allah will guide him and I'm pretty sure
you know he already do a lot of good
stuff what people don't do he helps a
lot of people he you know he helps a lot
he do a lot of stuff for a lot of
brothers you know he's a very very good
person and Shalala gonna guide him and
he's gonna be living this stuff
use this power you know the media power
the oldest like a bunch of followers and
people he's gonna make a doll wa
inshallah a known Allah will and he's
gonna bring a lot of people to the
straight path and you know a lot of
non-muslims following him and look his
lifestyle you know they hear this words
they hear how he talked the way he
treated people the way he act they
became interesting in Islam too so this
kind of Dowell like Muhammad Ali did in
his days back in the days he did a lot
of good stuff even they trying to put
the star with his name on the floor in
Hollywood and I know they put it on the
wall because he said I don't want this
because this name of my prophet so they
said ah so he did a lot of good for the
community you know so inshallah
all these brothers who is looking over
there and the fighter brothers you know
they're gonna open their hearts and
they're gonna understand you know this
dunya is doesn't mean nothing is
actually prison for the believer and I
mean insha'Allah they're gonna open
their hearts learn about Islam and
they're gonna use that you know use that
in expose and open up the human's eyes
to the religion of Islam to understand
the roots and the meaning and the real
Islamic Allah speaking of Dawa Muhammad
Ali we've all seen some of the the
videos have you seen where people are
asking Muhammad I'll leave what he's
gonna do you know with his life the
remainder when he retires and then he
brilliantly you know he goes into the
amount of time that's left in this world
the next 16 years what's the best thing
on me get ready to meet God
owning real estate learning business
teaching boxes that won't get me to
heaven God is watching me
God is God don't praise me because I
beat your aging God I'll cover but in
will America as far as real wealth
that's all he is
he wants to know how do we treat each
other how do we help each other so I'm
gonna dedicate my life to using my name
in popularity and helping charities
helping people uniting people bring
people bombing each other because the
religious believes we need somebody in
the world to help us uh make peace he
goes into you know working for his
afterlife he sees those opportunities
because God has power of all things if
you believe in him nothing even George
Foreman will look like a baby all the
way to the end you saw he was always you
know someone who is always God don't
look at our colors man's hearts have
known color God look at our minds and
our actions and our deeds so we have
white Muslims brown Muslims or he had
know somebody all emotions all colors
you know when he was asked who's your
bodyguard did you see that why did you
do have a bodyguard he hears the sees
those under quiet thoughts he stops
those who care with me the matchbox all
the time and when my heart trying to
sleep to the scene I put the fire on my
palm and I feel this heat and I see I
cannot even help this how I'm gonna
handle the Hellfire so this guy was
brilliant I mean and that's why he still
remembered to this day so he showed how
we can motivate some of the brothers who
are out there who are courageous is
enough to get in a cage and octagon even
though like you said they're going
against was pleasing to Allah but now
inshallah they had the courage to you
know leave it off but while they're
there to actually help to share to help
to go ahead and to raise some awareness
and just thinking about this brother can
you imagine if you encourage some people
to learn stored on Fatiha you know what
I mean and read this every day
one person can you imagine how many
times is going to come to you is
American yeah how many people are gonna
became a Muslims and you was the one who
all that make your reason for this
person to became a Muslim in your
position subhanAllah you can make so
much good for this then you know for
this
oh my you know for the Muslim brothers
because there's so many people who is
like you Roman for them right now they
so proud the Muslim became a UFC fighter
this is a huge in this dunya you know
what I mean but like subhanAllah you can
do so much good for that you know it
just yet your brothers you use this
power like I always I talk to the
brothers and I was telling make more
tower in your social minute you so much
Allah made it easy look you don't
imagine if we had to go door-to-door
knocking on a thousand doors to go ahead
and share this message but now with you
got millions of that's another great
example through the social media now
Allah he made eight that you can acquire
a lot of you know bad deeds or good
deeds by sharing sharing now here this
simple message of motivation
encouragement for people to reflect and
think there was a fighter who out there
and it's amazing he got out and he had a
shirt how I love Jesus Muslims love
Jesus did you ever see that it was
circulating so little things like that
that you can do one you mentioned the
social media Habib you say he does this
in the Russian I do always in Russian he
mentioned it he always put the quotes on
the Quran he always say stuff you know I
mean here we support the brothers all
over the world you know there you know a
lot of people these days don't know
talked about the Syria because they
scare the mention but the kids die go
there every day
why does not mention we talk about the
Conor McGregor destroying the bus
but we don't talk about the kids dying
every day just yesterday this was a
chemical attack on Syria and I was
seeing I was a crying I'm a dolt I'm a
man you know I was crying because I was
little to see little kids we don't have
to be Muslims we don't have to do we
have to be human beings when you see the
kids dying how cannot this touch your
heart this breaking my heart buzzkill
humanity is dumb and people don't talk
about this does not you know the little
kids was dying from the chemical attack
and nobody do nothing about that but
this little thing happened somewhere in
Europe everybody is talking about this
there's enough men Muslims have to talk
we have to speak up especially people
now that have the platforms that's
amazing what you just said like you know
Conor McGregor and that's another thing
like that you as a role model right now
this person throw is you know acting
like you know pretend gangster and
whatnot like Burger King chicken King
whatever they came right and now people
we've already become like this middle
finger culture people don't respect
they're out there there's no respect for
authority but now you're a role model
people are looking up to you you can set
good trends or bad trends and now you
have people like Conor McGregor
obviously setting bad trends you know
what I mean but now you as a Muslim MMA
fighter who's out there you have a big
following should be setting good trends
and being good example how people doing
these days and there's was many brothers
I know Omari has made a Sultana leave
gusano mulatto Rasheed magamaev all the
brothers who I don't mention sorry I
love you all my brothers they're all
doing a great job they all spread the
word of Islam you know what I mean they
fight but at least they do they part
they put the little seats in the heart
of the people and Allah will make it
grow you know sha Allah you're also I
had not - not too long ago I've had our
brother he's from from where where my
family's from Missha
baptism and then follows with me it
ain't no way no man can win no
ah man I feel like that summer I can
definitely relate to and know in a lot
of ways I was undefeated I remember did
every prayer every day went to mosques
at night and then I remember before my
last fight - I kind of got away from me
and I kind of questioned it sometimes
but it is I know it's not good and just
just hang him say that now it's like I'm
God maybe just woke me up a little bit
I do think differently now about a lot
of things right people like him also in
shot law you know having he's he's an
up-and-coming and maybe you trained with
him right you know I'm very well future
champ he's really tough guy gosh I love
but subhanallah is a very good brother
you see he get attached to he see the
brothers around here he see us praying
you get attached man now it's like I say
I see him in the Masjid more than myself
masha'Allah listen this really is I'm so
happy to hear that and so brothers like
him you know brother he's actually went
he's in Z now with training with another
Muslim in Canada he changes the Hara
yeah yeah so he's apparently he's a good
Muslim brother too and dislike a lot of
Muslims over there you know they get
close you know brothers getting close to
each other you know you should have to
be example for me and I often say
because you know when I talk about being
unapologetically Muslim it's no you know
we respect people of all religions all
faiths we're all brothers and sisters in
humanity but now there's no doubt that
Muslims there's a rise it's a it's a
quarter of a million dollar industry
bashing its Nam fighting against Muslim
Islamophobia is on the rise and that's
why I say we need to step up and be all
apologetic Lee Muslim so you are
approachable you can get to know us and
see that Muslims aren't you know
terrorists Muslims aren't your boogeyman
coming to get you where people just like
you who want to live in peace with our
neighbors and we're open for you to ask
questions get to know us and connect
with us make the human connection
because you have a lot of misconceptions
and people who are out there distorting
the image of Islam and people who are
trying to create fear of Muslims so now
the people who are out there like the
Mossad Beck ditch and Habib and other
fighters King MO and all these guys say
changes for mo too
how many be good examples and set a good
example for others to follow
not just it's easy to be you know
falling in line with the Conor
McGregor's but to be someone like
Muhammad Ali the Malcolm X is people who
stood up for justice and civil rights
and you know like you said talk about
real issues like Syria Gaza people who
are dying you know to me while we're
over here you know enjoying you don't
have to talk about this to where you
don't stand up and talk for ourselves to
like you need to be stopped being scared
you know shame you know like growing
your beard because you're gonna look
some type of different or stuff like
this no you're a Muslim you have to
represent you have to be proud and when
you're gonna expose this religion to
other people they they're not gonna be
fear to because all they see in the
media they scared when you show yourself
they're gonna open up and they're gonna
understand the real Islam and the truth
about this religion you know I was
punching people for living I was you
know but who stopped me from doing that
they slap the Dean you know the religion
of Islam stopped me because it's
forbidden by religion
I cannot hurt another human being that
God says in the Quran if you kill one
innocent person that's like it cooled
humanity nobody say this one over there
yeah
I want to thank you brother thank you
for being with us here on the Deen show
this is our brother Ali from Dagestan or
Ossetia this awesome awesome yeah
and all the brothers tuning in and if
you haven't subscribed subscribe already
tune in every week to the Deen show and
the message is simple worship the
Creator not the creation he said
guidance over time messengers out of his
love and it's always been the same
message one God worship Him alone not
his creation do good deeds and prepare
for Jenna paradise avoid the Hellfire
it's there in the Quran tamper free
Tampa proved a simple believable message
we'll see you next time peace be with
you soon like many people in your part
of the world Dagestan and other places
in Russia they've been asking me said
what's up with hobby where's he at he's
been on like I said every other show
except the Deen show maybe he don't
understand my english keep it humble
tell him how do you say it in your
language so we can make sure he got the
message
so now alaikum brother before to
progression a show
lettin us brought your show
the girls in the shop apology on
privilege a touch more artistic to
premium Islam enye de3 my city but
almost annually to do Beattyville Shell
its most pretty Punk over its name you
heard it Oh Polly got you the message we
hope to see you soon brother Salam
alaykoum dr. Apgar too